[Music]
you are playing linda lovelace
uh famous uh porn actress in a movie uh
that has not come out yet the film and
i'm just curious how do you portray a
porn star without the film being
incredibly explicit do you know what i
mean well you don't actually have sex
on film
you don't you don't actually write that
yeah this is not the way
um
which is not the way i would have gone
but i'm not directing
some say tomatoes some say tomato well
it would be it would it would it would
you know be categorized as porn then yes
yes what we do is we simulate these
things and um and we don't show
um we don't show certain
genitalia
and uh i use that well i for instance um
linda lovelace is famous for deep throat
so i had to do um some oral sex and and
we would use a popsicle which is great
because um it would make my
make my lips wet and
and uh
and
inflamed
and then
i honestly i can't believe i went that
far just now
i'm sorry my soul left my body
i'm a little there's a conan up on the
moon right now he doesn't even know so
so you're using this but i understand
now that works in the scene i mean
people
uh can see i mean who's the other actor
in this scene where you're using a
popsicle peter sarsgaard and he's such a
gentleman um
it was
sticky it was just it was awkward but
the thing is they're all it's always
awkward it's a it's a very serious movie
in fact but but it but we had so much
fun doing it because uh none of it's
real right and we're uh we just had to
make fun of the situation so that just
sounds comical at a certain point it
sounds like it gets so ridiculous and
there's people around you with cameras
and you've got a popsicle yeah and i'm
and i'm
doing this stuff
and it's
it's weird yeah
so on the days and then it's and then
it's like what did you do at work today
you know it's
my my adr lines which is the additional
recording that you do that's what you
add in later on yeah in the sound studio
was uh slurping noises
seriously
and uh
oh gosh
i am i'm promoting les mis right now yes
let's talk about lessons yes a film for
the whole family
we have more pencils um
les mis the costumes in this show
are fantastic i think we have a
photograph here of you in costume and i
understand that they're they're so heavy
and so thick and you were shooting in
the heat that you fainted i did i yeah
god what didn't it what another extreme
um that costume right you go from linda
lovelace and then suddenly you're woohoo
lots of wool lots of hot set in the
summer yeah fainted it was one of the
most terrifying experiences of my life
and then i woke up and russell crowe was
holding my legs and hugh jackman was
massaging my shoulders i'm telling you
i could do that again yeah
i've had that same dream
it's incredible no it's really it was
magical actually
except for the fact that when you faint
sometimes you think you're gonna pee
because you lose all control you know
what it's like right i don't think i've
fainted but i don't uh but you know
but you're that's what you're worried
about when i woke when i came to i was
like
this is so wonderful but did i pee
myself and i didn't
what a wonderful thing to say coming out
of a dreams that's not what dorothy said
when she woke up in the cabin you don't
know that
she was like i didn't pee myself did i
we have we have a clip here from les mis
anything we need to know for this clip
or should we just let her just let it
rip
dear mom
won't you say
[Music]
will you die
[Music]
and mine's cassettes
i don't know what to say
[Music]
i am lost
[Music]
[Applause]
that's exactly what it was like when
andy and i met for the first time
it was a butterfly